bonjour bonjour pierrot dupuy alors vous
êtes habitués maintenant de cette
émission que c'est la deuxième fois en
trois ans ça commence
et là je vous invitais parce que vous
êtes un peu en pointe dans le combat
contre les symboles aux pommes c'est pas
mais peuvent monopole du groupe hayotte
dans l'outre-mer de façon générale je
rappelle couderc président de
l'association et public des miles au
maire qui une association qui arrive
plein voyage et là je suis sur votre
page facebook
vous êtes aux antilles 1 kw à mayotte et
à la réunion un coup et vous essayez de
pouvoir choisir lequel des filières
locales et j'ai aussi noté que vous
étiez intervenue assez fortement contre
le projet de rachat de vindémia par le
groupe hayotte soin d'expliquer pourquoi
alors ça et pierrot dupuy le problème de
nos deux dans une grosse territoires
d'outre-mer vos territoires d'outre-mer
c'est en réalité la cherté de la vie le
chômage mais la cherté de la vie et le
chômage n'est s'il fait qu' un certain
nombre d'entreprises ou un certain
nombre de jeunes chefs d'entreprise ne
peuvent pas monter des entreprises parce
que l'horizon est bouché et le vrai
problème qui est au dessus c'est l'accès
aux marchés c'est ça le fond du problème
est le président de la république
lorsque il est venu voyage officiel jeu
juste une parenthèse pour l'ignorer j'ai
déjà dit à plusieurs reprises mais vous
avez été le référent de la clique en
marche votre mère blanca macron oui je
ne sais pas tout ce scoop pour personne
non ce qui nous mettrait pas je préfère
me dire comme ça on a une dizaine qui
n'osaient jantes et j'étais son invité
dans le dernier voyage officiel qui nous
a amenés à mayotte et à la réunion donc
j'étais c'était là évidemment ces jeux
soutien à titre personnel des manuels me
considère pas la doxa des raids homme
est un homme oeuvre de manière c'est une
une association de 1901 dont il a dominé
des gens qui n'ont pas forcément macro
nist mais moi à titre personnel je suis
profondément
dans les lignes du président république
n'est digne que je défends depuis
toujours
mendès france rocard et macron pour moi
c'est une ligne philosophique politique
économique que je défends donc je suis
très à l'aise avec ça on vient
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un peu plus pour
les territoires d'outre-mer
oui alors revenons que vous disais donc
lorsque présent d'un public et est à la
réunion c'était le 26 ou 27 octobre
qu'est ce qu'il nous dit et ne dit il
faut en finir avec les monopoles les
oligopoles pensée pour voguer de 10,6
nymex du poignet reynolds président de
république qui le dit et là avec
l'opération l'un des biens on est dans
une situation qui est une situation
j'aimerais qu'elle soit ubuesque le
problème c'est que là on n'est pas dans
une pièce de théâtre on est dans une
aide en réalité la réalité
bon c'est un groupe le groupe d'abord
quoi dire de ce groupe bernard hayot
tout d'abord c'est un groupe extrêmement
structurée qui a à sa tête des gens
extrêmement compétents dont on n'a pas à
faire des amateurs on affaire à des gens
qui sont de très haut financiers c'est
un groupe immensément riche qui a bâti
une fortune colossale depuis des
dizaines et des dizaines pour pas dire
des centaines d'années donc on a affaire
là
vient d en team qui vient des antilles
qui vient de martinique martinique
l'origine le berceau c'est la martinique
puis évidemment
ensuite la guadeloupe toute proche donc
on a affaire là un groupe industriel
extraordinairement structurés dont le la
doxa dont la vocation principale c'est
de faire des sous et de faire des souris
encore des sous pourquoi n'importe quel
groupe international mais c'est ne
jamais s'arrêter en faire encore et
toujours plus d'eau il n'y a pas de
vocation véritablement aider les
populations à vocation c'est de faire de
croître de prendre des parts de marché
et s'enrichir sessad à vos questions
alors qu'est ce que c'est contestable
pour faire du bon boulot de chef
d'entreprise est-ce que ça convient
aujourd'hui au développement des
territoires
notre mère j'ai tendance à penser que
non donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui jeudi
là il faut peut-être mettre un stop élan
pour penser que non peut-être que l'on
peut regarder ce qu'ils ont fait aux
antilles et qu'elle la situation aux
antilles avec je dirais bayonne alors là
omis puissant là encore plus qu'à la
réunion
je m'aime pas si des plus puissants il
est tellement puissant la meinau moi
j'étais au courant de ce qui se passe
cette réunion mais pierrot dupuy j'ai vu
du travail extraordinaire que vous avez
fait donc je me suis dit pétards il
reste encore une presse indépendante
à la réunion nous mais vous savez je
sais bien un pierrot dupuy ce qui se
passe lorsque nouvelles sanctions voilà
j'imagine que dès lors que vous avez
comme ça fait cet article vous aurez
peut-être - moins d'un coup du tout et
même plus du tout d'annonce dans les
entreprises qui sont comme ils sont
omniprésents ils sont partout et des
gros annonceurs
on sait très bien qu'on va voir souffrir
moi je salue votre courage en tout cas
parce que vous le faites je trouve que
c'est bien vous battez aussi dans la
ligne du président de la république qui
dit qu' il faut plus de monopole et puis
d'oligopole donc merci écoutez en tout
cas vous ne faites voilà bon
en martinique des spasmes en martinique
il ya plusieurs problèmes d'abord il
faut savoir qu'en martinique tous les
samedis les centres commerciaux de
bernard alioth sont assiégées par des
gens qui sont pas contents donc déjà on
a des troubles à l'ordre public qui sont
des troubles à l'ordre public important
jeunes viennent et quand on ne sait pas
alors ça c'est tous les samedis les gens
viennent pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
la cherté de la vie qui est
insupportable
ensuite parce que les gens sur place
sont pas contents du tout du scandale de
la chlordécone la chlordécone c'est ce
sera nos prix et qui a été répandu
partout dans la en martinique et en
guadeloupe qui aujourd'hui provoque man
mais oui pour déminer jurançon mais le
problème c'est que les gens meurent
aujourd'hui et les rumeurs car son été
avec des gens meurent aujourd'hui le
taux de cancer de la prostate
extrêmement élevé dont il ya juste un
truc
est-ce que je vais avoir un procès
demain matin si je vous dis que c'est le
frère de bernard elliott qui vendait à
travers les établissements la garrigue
le produit en question
donc je pose aussi une question est ce
que bernard alioth lui-même ignorait que
lorsqu ils vendaient des bananes qui
étaient produites en martinique sé bann
avait subi un traitement aussi violent
et qui pouvait mettre en danger la vie
des gens qui ramassent ses bananes
on peut quand même se poser des
questions morales donc aujourd'hui les
martiniquais sont en train de se battre
content il ya eu une grève très
importante en 2009 qui était la grève
contre la profitation et l'a de nouveau
on est de nouveau dans une dans un
moment extrêmement difficile les gens
comprennent pas vous avez vu
les gilets jaunes qui sont des gens qui
sont des gens n'ont pas beaucoup de
choses et qui sont montés en ligne parce
qu'ils étouffent et mais bon le
président de la république a fait ce
qu'il fallait pour mettre 10 milliards
d'euros pour pau pour essayer de réduire
cette fracture mais là-bas en martinique
cette fracture elle est encore plus
vivre qu'ailleurs
pourquoi parce que on a un groupe
principal groupe économique d'objets bh
et sauge et bh il est dans une telle
situation de de quasiment plus avoir de
concurrence sauf en tout cas sur très
peu de secteurs que il ya un étouffement
complet encore une fois ça veut dire
quoi c'est vrai que les gens qui veulent
aujourd'hui créer des entreprises dans
les domaines tous les secteurs qui sont
les secteurs qui ont à peu près des
débouchés la plupart des secteurs sont
entre m
ils sont pris donc vous voulez fléron
dit aujourd'hui que la martinique et de
la guadeloupe se dépeuple et c'est vrai
se dépeuple à vitesse grand v pourquoi
parce que vous avez une telle hégémonie
d'un seul groupe ou bien vous faites ce
qui vous demande ou bien vous partez et
aujourd'hui les jeunes diplômés partent
donc oui ça c'est pas bien moins douces
été très choqué pierrot dupuy par peur
quelque chose le directeur général qui
dirige les supermarchés du groupe
bernard hayot est allé / france /
françois ozon l'été sur martinique la
première et qu'est ce qui nous dit vous
pouvez voir revoir cette interview et
nous d'écouter ça coûte cher au groupe
hayotte d'avoir tous les samedis des
gens pas content et comme ça coûte cher
ben c'est nos salariés qui vont en pâtir
c'est que peut-être qu'on pourra pas
leur payer des primes de fin d'année
écoutez mais moi je suis sidéré on a là
un problème qui est aprem sociétal avec
des gens qui viennent je ne justifie pas
les violences pas du tout mais ce
problème là ce problème qui est un
problème où ces gens là ils vont venir
en montrer dans les emprises du groupe
bernard yonne leur mécontentement en
l'occurrence sur le corps déconne bon
donc ils utilisent ce qu'ils estiment à
ils ont tort de faire ça mais comment le
groupe hayotte peut-il faire reposer et
in fine et le coût de ce genre
d'intervention sur ses propres salariés
sachant qu'un côté font des bénéfices
monstrueux sachant qu'à côte est une
entreprise qui est comme je vous l'aï
dit tout à l'heure
remarquablement géré c'est à dire
remarquablement riche donc enfin
franchement moi je suis très choqué de
d'utiliser ce nom de boucliers humains
pour tyr au fond écoutez attention je
dresse un peu des uns contre les autres
donc moi j'ai été très choqué très
sincèrement très choqué par cela encore
une fois je ne justifie pas les les
attaques des supermarchés
je rappelle clairement à d'autres formes
d'autres formes de 2,2 bondirait de
contestation il faut que être pacifique
il faut absolument pas déraper dans la
violence mais la réponse qui est faite
aujourd'hui par bernard iott est une
réponse terrible au nom à la réunion de
l'enclavé des différentes enquêtes que
nous avons menées ici les infos les
infographistes fut dit on voit bien que
la stratégie du groupe hayotte en fait
on repère les secteurs les plus
rentables et on investit massivement
dedans de façon à arriver en position au
minimum occupé 40 à 50 % de part de
marché
quand tout un groupe unique vont peser
50 % de parts de marché et que les 50 %
qui restent sont éparpillés entre une
multitude de petites sociétés
il est en position de quasi-monopole
parce que cette impression de n'imposer
ce que vous voulez là aujourd'hui il est
question que le campagnol rachète
madénian presse sera jamais unia pour
vous et dangereux
le groupe hayotte pèse déjà très lourd
dans le panier de la ménagère
donc augmenter les parts de marché de ce
groupe ça veut dire plusieurs choses
d'abord ça veut dire que l'accès aux
filières laitières du production le
groupe hayotte il se contente pas
d'avoir du front-office c'est à dire des
magasins pour vendre il est aussi un
acteur direct ou indirect dans la
production donc par exemple production
dédiée aux produits des yaourts ici à la
réunion vous a pas de débat sauf que le
producteur qui est le producteur qui
n'est pas affilié au groupe hayotte
hilarion qui fait de m tandis que lego
les yaourts qui sont produits ici par le
groupe hayotte depuis il a un rayon très
large on dit oui mais pas parce qu'il a
une moins grande gamme
il peut pas avoir une grande gamme dès
lors qu' il n'est pas vendu à armes
égales avec les autres on s'est loupé
dans la grande distribution 20 mai
mais naturellement et moi j'étais votre
attention sur plusieurs phénomènes
comment sont nées ces grands groupes ces
groupes y sont nés en horizontal et
vertical pourquoi en horizontale c'est à
dire les magasins des surfaces de vente
partout les gens vont parce que ces
emprises la craie des emprises
importantes et puissantes elles sont
nées avec la surrémunération la
surrémunération est un élément
fondamental du développement du business
de ces groupes là d'accord ce qui fait
d'ailleurs que comme n'y a pas de prix
dans les magasins un prix pour ceux qui
sont sur rémunérés et puis un prix pour
les autres ceux qui n'ont pas la
surrémunération se trouve dans une
position extrêmement difficile et puis
également l'argent public qui est
l'acheminement de dés des clients dans
ces centres là il ya de l'asv'olt ça
coûte cher des routes
quand il ya des promotions sur les
ronds-points et les forces de l'ordre
etc donc c'est de l'argent public puis
vous avez de l'argent public dans
l'autre sens c'est à dire que quand on a
en fabrique canton 30 contrôle d'une
filière économique de prendre le contôle
suffire économique c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est à dire si vous faites
encore une fois je reprends les exemples
du yaourt pour faire des yaourts vous
avez ce qu'on appelle les fonds possible
les fonds positions du fonds européen
qui permette de dire puisque vous devez
fabriqué en plus petites quantités
vous allez fabriquer plus cher donc du
coup l'europe vous donner un peu
d'argent
les stores milliards d'euros perdus puis
en milliards d'euros
par ailleurs vous avez ce qu'on appelle
les fonds structurels européens
donc là c'est pour
investissements notamment pour les
locaux et autres donc les fonds feder
les fonds feader et c'est là encore de
l'argent public
puis vous avez encore la défiscalisation
pierrot dupuy donc voyez tous ces
dispositifs financiers là ils sont en
milliards d'euros un milliard d'euros
mais moi je suis pas en train de vous
faire une image là un milliard d'euros
par exemple c'est un milliard de pièces
de un euro qui sont mises bout-à-bout
savez avec un milliard de pièces d'un
euro
je crois que quelqu'un calculé confins
de cette fois le tour de la terre en
faisant un chapelet donc ça fait ça fait
des sous et c'est plusieurs milliards
d'euros donc je dis aujourd'hui que cet
argent public qui a été pris légalement
un le gouverneur eliot en troc mais
c'est le plus puissant
donc on n'est pas là pour se dire des
pourparlers du sexe des anges
on est la pose de la vérité dispose
d'outils qu'il a le pied qu'il a
contribué à créer un outil qui est
heureux d'hommes qui est une société
enfin en tout cas une organisation qui
est très puissante et qui est à
beauzelle et qui est une reddition de
lobby dont c'est le métier
encore une fois tout ça n'est rien
d'illégal dans tout ce que je suis en
train de vous dire il n'y a rien
d'illégal
sauf que ça aboutit à une situation qui
est une situation de 2,10 père monopole
là on n'est pas au monopole en étant
hyper monopole vous avez aimé vous en
évidence le fait que 80% des camions qui
roulent à la réunion sont vendus par le
groupe hayotte écouter objectivement ça
veut dire quoi j'avais un petit
transporteur que j'ai vu lors de mon
passage à la réunion kim a dit max mon
problème c'est que moi je veux pas
acheter des camions dans les enseignes
du groupe hayotte bon très bien et 10
mai quand je vais livrer ming avec ce
camion là qui n'est pas camions qui
sortent du groupe hayotte ces mêmes les
chefs de quelques immédiat tiens ton
camion etc
donc on fait alors il n'y a même pas
besoin de faire pression est ce que le
groupe ait fait une pression directe à
nous est jamais mais à un moment donné
tout le monde sait ça il ya une telle
hégémonie vous savez très bien que si
vous n'allez pas dans le sens de celui
qui a tout le pouvoir financier vous
savez bien que quelque part il va pas
vous faire un cadeau au quartz fixe il
vous à celui-ci donc ça c'est
ça donne quoi au bout de ligne ça donne
un nom accès au marché donc le marché
est verrouillé tous les marchés qui sont
les marchés prenable ils sont ils sont
quasiment verrouillé
donc quelqu'un peut pas s'installer dès
lors qu'ils s'installent il faut qu'il
passe sous les fourches caudines de
celui qui est déjà puissamment installé
ça veut dire que les jeunes tout le
boulot ça veut dire que les filières ne
se développe pas comme elle devrait se
développer
peut-être que plus d'intelligence et
quand on a beaucoup d'argent on tient le
marché en tenant le marché finalement
n'est parfois pas obligé de progresser
beaucoup technologiquement quand on est
en concurrence la concurrence est vive
elle vous oblige à trouver des solutions
pour être un peu meilleur que le voisin
là c'est la puissance financière qui
tient l'ensemble
donc moi je veux dire je souhaite longue
vie aux compagnes hot faut pas se
tromper
je souhaite longue vie mais je lui dis
arrêtez de vous arrêter de bouffer tous
les marchés la à la réunion c'est le
patro ils en ont déjà assez pierrot
dupuy gagne déjà largement leur vie
voyez prenez un exemple imaginer ce qui
est quand même pas de la science fiction
qu un jour y ait un mouvement social
dans le groupe hayotte ça peut arriver
un mouvement social peu de temps en
temps on fait un essayé de tenir mais
s'il avait un mouvement social avec une
telle puissance puissance renforcée
aujourd'hui par ce qu'ils prendraient
éventuellement comme parts de marché
supplémentaires
le seul groupe hayotte qui tomberait
aujourd'hui sous le coup d'un mouvement
social bloquerait intégralement la
réunion intégralement
il suffirait d'un mouvement social à
l'intérieur d'un groupe pour que toute
l'économie de la réunion s'arrête
oui donc s'il ya un grand danger à ça
donc encore une fois moi j'ai rien
contre monsieur ayotte compte bernard
alioth strictement rien je suis
aujourd'hui dans la doxa de déré
d'hommes développeurs aujourd'hui de
l'économie et des filières nous nous
voulons développer les filières pays
nous voulons aujourd'hui que dans tous
les territoires les jeunes qui sont les
jeunes réunionnais les jeunes mahorais
martiniquais guadeloupéens polynésie
de nouvelle calédonie et d'autre on veut
c journal il est une chance mais pour
avoir une chance il faut qu'ils puissent
avoir eux mêmes qu'ils maîtrisent leur
débauche et qu'ils maîtrisent leur
commercialisation
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
moi je crois que d'abord il faut je fais
un appel aux paillotes alors 10 1
écoutez
prenez conscience que cette position
terrible que vous prenez de vouloir
bouffer intégralement la réunion c'est
le coup de trop quoi là il ya un moment
donné il faut il faut savoir raison
garder et se dire bon est-ce que copilot
encore besoin d'en avaler autant c'est
un groupe solide qui pourrait faire tout
à fait la fierté de la france qu'il
allait aujourd'hui encore développer son
business en dehors des frontières il pas
obligé de venir encore prendre une
position encore plus aisés monique à la
réunion il ya des territoires qui sont
autour dans lesquelles il peut avoir des
conquête commerciale
d'ailleurs les dispositifs français sont
tout à fait à sa disposition pour
l'aider à y conquérir des marchés
donc ne nous trompons pas je ne suis pas
anti ayotte
je suis simplement un homme qui réfléchi
aux conséquences sociales aux
conséquences économiques
je sais que c'est un étouffement complet
je dis aujourd'hui que il faut qu'on
revienne calmement je souhaite moi que
l'autorité de la concurrence prennent en
compte l'ensemble de ces paramètres et
de ce risque là et alors on va dire oui
mais l'autorité de la concurrence va
leur mettre de telles contraintes que
ces contraintes l'a finalement ça va
réduire et ça va être acceptable sauf
que avec pierrot dupuy les contraintes
c'est un moment donné est-ce que les
contraintes qu'on met ensuite sont
véritablement respecter ça c'est pas sûr
voyez donc moi je préfère tenir que
courir je préférais que l'autorité de
concurrence si elle le peut ses montants
prenne son temps parce ce qu'on appelle
en face d'eux c'est à dire une phase de
réflexion complémentaire
moi j'ai vu ou lu ça fait trois jours
que je suis réunion j'ai rencontré
le fait chaque fois une quinzaine de
chefs d'entreprise que je vois dans leur
entreprise
aucun de ces quinze chefs d'entreprise
que j'ai vu ne m'a dit sa satisfaction
de voir le groupe gbh remporté aucun et
ces gens là
parfois je sais que eux mêmes entre eux
et c'est même pas nécessairement ces
entrepreneurs donc parfois ils sont
concurrents parfois ils ont un passif
comme ça donc on peut pas dire que il ya
une cohésion entre mais chacun va dit la
même chose batimac cela c'est pas
possible
là c'est tellement c'est une une telle
emprise que la save à déréguler déréglé
complètement le système économique
réunionnais aucun je vous assure puis
roux du puy bien mes côtés ben on aura
l'occasion de ce roman parce que la
décision de l'ap toto riina datant
maintenant pas très très longtemps donc
en fonction il souhaite de nouveau de
nos parages on pourrait essayer
d'analyser et de commenter cette
décision avec un merci merci à vous en
tout cas et puis encore une fois plein
de belles choses à mes amis réunionnaise
réunionnais est juste un dernier message
réunionnais réunionnaise est une chose
que je vais vous dire si on produit
localement
si on mange le clown mention produit
localement on a des emplois locaux donc
il faut défendre ces filières csssae
rennes-om nous on défend pas les grands
groupes on défend des filières et des
filières les plus autonomes possible il
faut faire ça très bien merci merci
pierrot dupuy
à bientôt